إنه الفيديو الذي لا تريد المراكز الصينية
أن تشاهده أو تشاركه
لأنه أشعل انتفاضة رقمية نادرة على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في نهاية هذا الأسبوع لتسليط الضوء على
البؤس والعجز المشترك الذي شعرت به
شنغهاي
[تصفيق]
يشير الفيديو إلى خلل في
إدارة المدينة في حالة فوضى تكافح من
أجل التغلب عليها  مع ارتفاع عدد حالات كوفنت ،
فإن صدى ذلك كان مع العديد من سكان شنغهاي البالغ
عددهم 25 مليونًا الذين يشعرون بأنهم محاصرون
ويلجأون إلى ويبو ويتشات للتنفيس
وسط ما تسيطر عليه الحكومة من
الإنترنت مع أي نزول يتم
إخماده سريعًا ومحو أجهزة الاستشعار الصينية
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع.
هل سيحظرون نسخة واحدة
من الفيديو؟
فيلم 2012 les mis الإشارة إلى
انتفاضة القرن التاسع عشر في ص  نشأت أجهزة الاستشعار التي تم ضبطها
بسرعة لإطفاء
الانتشار ،
لكن المستخدم يستهدف أيضًا
الرقابة الواضحة نفسها التي
تشارك مقاطع لمسؤوليها الذين
يعلنون أن مواطني الصين لهم
الحق في التعبير عن أنفسهم بحرية على
ما يبدو أمرًا مثيرًا للسخرية نظرًا حتى السطر الأول
من النشيد الوطني الصيني هو
الآن محجوبة على الإنترنت ، الكلمات ترتفع أولئك
الذين لا يريدون أن يتم استعبادهم الآن تستخدم
كمرجع مستتر لانتقاد
حكومتهم لأن بعض شنغهاي تشعر
وكأنها أكبر سجن في العالم.
باب الإرهابي هنا ، نحن محظوظون
بما فيه الكفاية للحصول على بعض الهواء النقي
خارج
مجتمعنا المتطوع الذي أرسل لي هذه
الصورة لما يوجد على الجانب الآخر من
بابنا ختمًا ورقيًا حديثًا
لتذكير بعدم
المغادرة وإذا تمكنت من الخروج هناك  الآن
حارس كوفيد نشر ليلًا ونهارًا على الرغم من
أن شخصًا ما يمكن أن يتخطى الأمر لأنه
يستسلم للإرهاق
خارج أسوار مجمعات سكنية عديدة
.  عند مشاركة الجيران
بصور مروعة للحواجز الجديدة على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
استمع إليهم وهم يصرخون من شرفاتهم
حيث أنهم محبوسون في أقفاص في
بعض إيجاد حلول بديلة لشراء
البقالة من خلال الطبقة المضافة ،
والبعض الآخر يزعج الأقفال بشدة على
أمل الهروب
ومن ثم هناك من تمكن من ذلك
هدم الجدران
للأشخاص المحبوسين في منازلهم
مثل هذه هي حقيقة مرعبة
حريق في شقة خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في
منطقة الأعمال التجارية في شنغهاي ، وسارعت وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
إلى الإبلاغ عن خروج الجميع
بأمان ، لكنها تثير تساؤلات حول إمكانية أن
تكون هذه الحواجز المرغوبة أكثر من
خطر من الفيروس نفسه ، وإذا كنت
تعتقد أن المدينة قد تكون قريبة من إعادة فتح
أو تخفيف عمليات الإغلاق ، تظهر الصور من
شوارع شنغهاي
حاويات عملاقة لا تجلب الإمدادات التي تشتد الحاجة إليها
ولكنها تساعد في بناء
المزيد من الحصار ،
حيث يتم تقريب الحالات الأكثر إيجابية والمخالطين المقربين
تصل إلى
مرافق الحجر الصحي الحكومية ،
وترك البعض للنوم في الخيام في  وسط
الشوارع المهجورة حيث
يتم تطهير مهاجعهم
حيث أن صدى صدى السخط المتصاعد في
جميع أنحاء المدينة الفارغة بشكل مخيف
للعديد من
شنغهاي قد سقط ديفيد غطاء cnn
shanghai
[موسيقى]